après une journée de travail caniculaire
qui n'a pas rêvé de se jeter à l'eau ce
sera bientôt possible pour adrien il a
commencé les travaux de sa piscine il y
a deux mois pour une raison bien précise
mais était son plus en plus dur en ce
moment donc on a fait ça surtout pour la
chaleur et quand on voit qu'on atteint
les 42 hélas ces derniers jours c'est
sûr que ça donne envie de se mettre dans
l'eau cette vidéo se déplacer ça met du
charme à la maison ça mais de l'activité
il n'est pas le seul à avoir eu cette
idée le pisciniste qui terminent la
construction chez adrien a vu en un an
le nombre de ces chantiers doublé ces
modèles sont vendus à partir de 25000
euros
cela n'empêche pas son carnet de
commandes est trop bien remplie depuis
février on avait pas mal de nancray
dernière tout seul j'ai fait entre 10 et
15 piscine sur une année hélas pour
l'année complète je suis pas loin des 25
30 bassins
la france est d'ailleurs le premier parc
européen de piscines on en compte plus
de deux millions c'est une piscine pour
38 habitants
ce magasin spécialisé vend
principalement des kits de construction
c'est ce qui a fait augmenter son
chiffre d'affaires tous les ans était
quasiment 10% rend à peu près de
dévolution là cette année on va faire un
15 20% facile
les abandons profiter il faudra
patienter jusqu'au remplissage autorisée
malgré les restrictions
il s'agit d'une première mise en eau